so uh late last night
early this morning as the violent
trumpist rioters
were unable to stop the counting of the
electoral votes
in favor of joe biden being the next
president of the united states
donald trump through dan scavino
put out a statement that he is
agreeing to leave office on january 20th
now the the sick irony is
when he lost in early november
he was leaving office on january 20th
and so
i i have kind of mixed feelings and
mixed reactions to this
he finally is agreeing and yet it's
irrelevant
because he wasn't going to be president
anymore come noon eastern time on
january 20th
and even in his statement a quote
agreeing to leave office
donald trump still repeats the exact
same
uh inciting statements that led to the
violent trumpist mob rioters yesterday
in washington d.c
donald trump saying wow even though i
totally disagree with the outcome of the
election
and the facts bear me out that's a lie
nevertheless there will be an orderly
transition on january
20th while this represents the end of
the greatest first term in presidential
history
it's only the beginning of our fight to
make america great again
imagine the delusion imagine the
delusion donald trump
lost the house for republicans on 2018
in 2018 lost the senate for republicans
in 2020 and was made a one-term
president
amidst the most cartoonishly farcical
presidency we have ever seen we've never
seen
an actual uh a more authoritarian
president
in the united states the modern era of
politics
was not even prepared we learned for
something this absurd as
even many of the checks and balances
were were
impotent in actually holding trump
accountable for for his ignoring those
checks and balances
and trump says this was the best first
term of any president in history so it's
delusional
but the idea that only because trump has
agreed
this is going to be what takes place is
also just a a laughing stock and making
the united states a laughingstock
trump was leaving one way or the other
and the fact that it is so
newsworthy that he has now come out and
said i am agreeing to an orderly
transition of power is wild
but then what's the most important thing
the most important thing is that it's
too late
it it's already not an orderly
transition of power
and the fact that trump will fly off to
who knows where
on january 19th or january 20th and
golf and tweet if he's still even
allowed on twitter which is another
story for later today
it's it's already not an orderly
transition and i think that's what we
have to understand you know
as i said as we see some republicans now
back away from trump
they need to be held accountable for the
four years that they defended him and
in the same way that donald trump is now
backing away from
resisting leaving office and saying it
will be an orderly transition
the orderly has has uh that ship has
sailed
uh thousands of violent trumpists
stormed the capital yesterday breaking
in and doing all sorts of damage and
even leading to the death
of one woman uh the ship has sailed on
orderly
and we can't now allow trump to revise
the story by saying i'm going to leave
in an orderly fashion on january 20th
that ship has sailed and we will talk a
little bit later about what the next
several months
might look like let's take a quick break
make sure you're following the show on
instagram at davidpakmanshow and follow
me on instagram at david.pacman
start your day and your new year off
right with just egg which is one of our
sponsors you've heard me talk about the
importance of having a diet that is
more heavily plant-based than it's
something i've done
over the last few years i've always
loved eggs so it's great
that there is a delicious plant-based
version
of egg with all the protein of egg that
just egg brings with it but it's made
from
mung beans so it uses 98 percent less
water
and causes 93 percent fewer carbon
emissions than a conventional egg
and just egg cooks and tastes exactly
like a conventional egg i've tried it
for omelets
scrambled eggs french toast banana bread
pad thai anything you'd normally use
eggs for and i actually think if i
cooked something
for a friend without telling them about
just egg
they wouldn't even know the difference
find it in the egg
aisle at your grocery store on amazon
prime now
or on instacart and they also have a
frozen version
perfect for breakfast sandwiches just
egg try it out